Wait, I gotta go get my Lady Great tea, okay? I'll be back and we'll talk about that in like 30 seconds, but I need my hydration. Maybe I'm gonna pick up a strawberry Perrier as well, because, you know, I'd offer you one, but you know, you're in New York, so bad choice. There's so much to unpack, dear listener. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 43 recorded on September 11th, 2021. My name is Connor. And on today's episode with my co-host Bryce, we talk about parallel scans and what the associativity requirement on binary operations actually entails, as well as NASA plants, Ramanujan numbers, and more. Oh, see, I bet you expected me to be late, and that's why you weren't ready on time. Um, well, let's talk about this, Brycece you've been late 33 minutes once 28 minutes once you know the group that i used to play magic the gathering with in uh in california there may have
等一下，我去拿我的 Lady Great 茶，好吗？我马上回来，大概30秒后我们再聊那个，但我需要补水。也许我也顺便拿一瓶草莓味巴黎水，因为，你知道的，本来想请你喝一瓶，但你知道的，你在纽约，所以这选择太糟糕了。亲爱的听众，有太多东西要聊了。欢迎收听 ADSP，播客第 43 期，录制于2021年9月11日。我的名字是康纳。在今天的节目中，我的联合主持人布莱斯将和我们一起讨论并行扫描，以及二元运算的结合律要求究竟意味着什么，还有美国宇航局植物、拉马努金数等等。哦，看吧，我敢说你料定我会迟到，所以你才没有准时准备好。嗯，好吧，我们来聊聊这个，布莱斯，你曾有一次迟到33分钟，有一次迟到28分钟。你知道我以前在加利福尼亚州一起玩《万智牌》的那个群体吗，可能
been a few times where i was confused about whether we started at 6 p.m or or 7 p.m. on Friday nights. And so I showed up an hour late. And so they, of course, never let me forget it. And they started using Bryce as a verb to mean late. You know, so somebody would be like, oh, I'm going to be five minutes, or not as a verb, as a whatever part of speech it would be. I'm going to be five minutes Bryce. Yeah.
有过几次，我对我们是周五晚上6点还是7点开始感到困惑。所以我迟到了一个小时。于是他们当然从不让我忘掉这事，他们开始用“布莱斯”作为动词来表示迟到。你知道的，所以有人会说，哦，我要迟到五分钟，或者不是作为动词，而是作为某种词性。我要“布莱斯”五分钟。是的。
Wait, so you just indicated that I was missing out for having moved to New York, but I'm closer to where you are, so it would be more practical now for you to share a drink with me than it would have been when I was in California. Yeah, I guess that's true. That's true. Were you just suggesting that I made the wrong decision in not deciding to relocate to Toronto? Maybe. All right, here, listeners.
等等，所以你刚才暗示我因为搬到纽约而错过了什么，但我离你更近了，所以现在你和我一起喝一杯会比我在加利福尼亚时更切实可行。是的，我想这是真的。真的。你刚才是不是在暗示我决定不搬到多伦多是一个错误的决定？也许吧。好吧，听众朋友们。
Usually I would mute this this is the sound of a strawberry perrier being opened and it's gonna be it's gonna be magnificent you ready here we go actually that was pretty bad that's pretty i'm gonna cut that out or maybe i'll go get another maybe i'll go get another strawberry perrier later. My, what, you're going to re-record that? You're going to redo that? No, I mean, these things are only 250 milliliters. I'm going to pound through this in like 30 seconds. My stuff is here.
通常我会把这个静音，这是打开一瓶草莓味巴黎水的生意，这将会，这将会非常棒。准备好了吗？我们开始吧。其实这声音挺糟的，挺……我得把它剪掉，或者也许我待会儿再去拿一瓶，也许我待会儿再去拿另一瓶草莓味巴黎水。什么，你打算重新录音？你打算重来一次吗？不，我是说，这东西只有250毫升。我大概30秒就能把它喝光。我的东西到了。
Organized boxes. Well, all my boxes are here. I do have a bed. Yep. Our listeners are informed of all of your furniture and my furniture for that matter. We're keeping the listener. Hey? Yeah, yeah. There you go. Good one.
整理好的箱子。好吧，我所有的箱子都在这儿。我确实有一张床。是的。我们的听众被告知了你所有的家具，还有我的家具。我们要留住这位听众。嘿？耶，耶。给你。说得好。
I told Connor that we should start referring to our – when we break the fourth wall and talk directly to you, the listener, that we shouldn't talk about you, the listener, in the plural. We shouldn't say, you know, audience, you know, insert some fact about Connors here that I want to tell you directly or something like that. No, instead, I should directly address you, specifically you. Yes, you. Whoever's listening to this right now, because it creates a more personal experience for the podcast. I picked up that a lot of the big podcasts do this. Should we just assume also that everyone we talk about is a listener? So when we mention like, you know, Tony's name, we just say, Hey, Tony, how's it going? Oh, yeah, of course.
我告诉康纳，我们应该开始这样称呼我们的——当我们打破第四堵墙，直接跟你（听众）对话时，我们不应该用复数来称呼你（听众）。我们不应该说，你知道的，观众朋友们，你知道的，插入一些我想直接告诉你或类似事情的关于康纳的事实。不，相反，我应该直接称呼你，特别是你。是的，就是你。不管现在是谁在听这个，因为这为播客创造了更个人化的体验。我注意到很多大的播客都这样做。我们是不是也应该假设我们谈论的每个人都是听众？所以当我们提到，比如说，托尼的名字时，我们就说，嘿，托尼，最近怎么样？哦，是的，当然。
Of course. Because either they're listening and they feel special or they're not listening. And then we have a chance to guilt them over it later. Oh, yeah, that's a good point. Yeah, that's how we should grow our listener base, is through emotional manipulation. It is what my people are known for. So we gotta start things off by addressing the first ever ADSP, the podcast, Twitter poll, which was obviously, if you're a listener. I am unfamiliar with this.
当然。因为要么他们在听，并且觉得自己很特别，要么他们没听。然后我们就有机会事后为此让他们感到内疚。哦，是的，说得好。是的，这就是我们应该如何扩大我们的听众群，通过情感操纵。这就是我的人民所擅长的。所以我们得首先通过解决有史以来第一次 ADSP 播客 Twitter 投票来开始，很明显，如果你是一个听众的话。我对这个不熟悉。
It's when Bryce previously had said, quote, any civilized person knows what a credenza is. Now I do know. Now I do know what's happening. I posted the question. So I wasn't sure if I should have posted it. I have heard of or I have not heard of, like just a true false sort of thing, but I opted for like the balderdash. Let's make up things. So I put four options.
这是布莱斯之前说过的话，原话是：“任何文明人都知道什么是克伦萨（credenza）。”现在我知道了。现在我知道是怎么回事了。我发布了这个问题。所以我当时不确定我是不是应该发布它：“我听说过”或“我没听说过”，就像那种对错题一样，但我选择了类似荒诞不经的那种。让我们编造一些东西。所以我放了四个选项。
What is a credenza? A pastry, B luxury car, C furniture and D clothing. In last place with 4.7% was a luxury car. And I should also give myself some credit that when I said it sounded like a Ferrari Credenza, I think the reason why a bunch of people knew what this was is because they're Italian. And it's an Italian word,
什么是克伦萨？A.糕点，B.豪车，C.家具，D.服装。以4.7%的得票率垫底的是豪车。我还应该给自己点赞的是，当我说它听起来像一辆法拉利克伦萨时，我认为大家之所以知道这是什么，是因为他们是意大利人。这是一个意大利词，
and luxury cars mostly come from Italy and Germany, not to offend our German listeners. Did you capitalize Credenza in the poll? Because if you didn't, then obviously people would be like, well, yeah, it can't be a luxury car because otherwise it would be capitalized. Oh good point it was not capitalized i i'd done messed up all right all right so that was four what was three uh in third place was clothing at 11.2 percent i really should have instead of putting clothing after the fact i realized i
而豪车主要来自意大利和德国，无意冒犯我们的德国听众。你在投票中把“克伦萨”首字母大写了吗？因为如果你没大写的话，显然大家就会觉得，哦，对啊，它不可能是豪车，否则首字母就该大写了。哦，说得对，它没有大写。我搞砸了。好吧，好吧，那是第四个。第三个是什么？呃，排在第三位的是服装，占11.2%。我真的应该——在事后我意识到，比起放服装，我
should have put bicycle but that's okay in place, in third place with 21.3% was pastry. I'm not sure if that says more about people thinking it's a pastry or people thinking that if this is something about Bryce, it's a pastry. Which that means that in first place with 62.7% was furniture. So that means, what is that, 37.3%? I'm pretty sure that you switched the place ordering system that you were using in between the second place and the last one. Because you said in third place was pastry and then in first place was oh my bad yeah so fourth fourth was luxury car third was clothing second was pastry and uh first was furniture so yeah a grand total if my math is my math is correct uh 37.3 percent of people are
本来应该放自行车的，不过也没关系，第三名是糕点，得票率21.3%。我不确定这更能说明大家以为它是糕点，还是大家觉得如果这事和布莱斯有关，那它就是糕点。这意味着第一名是家具，得票率为62.7%。那也就是说，是多少来着，37.3%？我很确定你在第二名和最后一名之间切换了你一直在用的名次排序系统。因为你说第三名是糕点，然后第一名是——哦我的错，对，所以第四名是豪华轿车，第三名是服装，第二名是糕点，呃，第一名是家具。所以，如果我的数学没错的话，总共有——呃，37.3%的人是
uncivilized so i think you owe the listener 37.3% of the listener an apology, Bryce. I just want to say, dear listener, I'm really glad for the 67% of you that are sublimes. 63. 63. You're not rounding up to two-thirds there, buddy. You don't get to do that. Also, this doesn't work if we're referring to the listener with a poll where, how many people responded?
没文化的，所以我认为你欠听众一个道歉，37.3%的听众，布莱斯。我只想说，亲爱的听众，我真的很为那67%的订阅者感到高兴。63。63。老兄，你可没四舍五入到三分之二。你不能这么干。另外，如果我们用投票来指代听众，这就行不通了，话说有多少人参与了投票？
It's like 10. Oh, 169. Wow, that's 13 squared. That's pretty good. Why do you know that? Why do you know that? Doesn't everyone? Well, I don't know.
大概10个。哦，169个。哇，那是13的平方。真厉害。你怎么知道这个的？你怎么知道这个的？难道不是人人都知道吗？好吧，我不知道。
Like math nerds, I just assume have like all of their squares. Why did you, I like how you not only math words, I just assume, have like all of their squares. I like how you not only knew that, but you felt the need to just share it with the world right now. I mean, how often do you come across the number 169, you know? I don't know, but I have a feeling that somewhere you have some spreadsheet where you've written down every time you've come across. No, no. written down every time you've come across no no it's just like like i've never come across like the number 343 just like as a figure um but that's like my one of my favorite numbers that's seven cubed what are some of your other favorite numbers well we already well 42 1729 4104 anything that's
像数学书呆子那样，我只是默认他们掌握了所有的平方数。你为什么——我喜欢你不仅知道这个，而且还觉得有必要现在就把它分享给全世界。我是说，你多久才会遇到169这个数字？我不知道，但我有一种感觉，你在某处有个电子表格，记录了你每一次遇到——不，不是。记录了你每一次遇到——不，不，这就像——就像我从来没遇到过343这个数字，作为一个具体的数字，但这确实是我最喜欢的数字之一，那是7的三次方。你还有哪些最喜欢的数字？好吧，我们已经——42、1729、4104，任何
a remodeling number uh yeah i'm so bad when i write uh when i write tests there's a Ramon Jean number? Yeah, I'm so bad when I write tests. There's a surprising number of tests that I write where the value 1742 or 3.14 is used as some value for testing purposes. Like, if you look through a bunch of uh you know tests in a code base that i've worked on and you see those numbers it was probably me that did it yeah that's uh it's uh yeah a lot of times when i'm just messing around 42 and 1729 are the the numbers that i that i throw in or 1729 so uh 1729 is the first Ramonajan number. What? Which is...
拉马努金数，呃，是的，我太糟糕了，自我——自我出题的时候，有惊人数量的测试是我出的，其中值1742或3.14被用作测试目的的某个值。比如，如果你浏览我参与过代码库中的一堆呃，你知道的测试，然后你看到了这些数字，那可能就是我干的。是的，那是个——呃，很多时候当我只是瞎胡闹的时候，42和1729就是我随手抛出的数字，或者是1729。所以，呃，1729是第一个拉马努金数。什么？也就是——
I covered this in a CPPCon talk, which means Bryce doesn't watch my talks. Also, Stefan Lawaway, in the same CPPCon of 2019, he snuck a bunch of 1729s in, which I pointed out in the same conference at my talk that was later in the week. So there's a movie called, well, Ramanujan is a famous mathematician. Yeah, I knew that. And there's a movie called, is it The Man Who Knew Everything?
我在CPPCon的演讲中讲过这个，这意味着布莱斯不看我的演讲。还有，斯特凡·洛威（Stefanus Lawawy），在同年的2019年CPPCon上，他塞了一堆1729进去，我在那周稍后进行的演讲中指出了这一点。所以有一部电影叫——好吧，拉马努金是一位著名的数学家。对，我知道。还有一部电影叫，是叫《知无涯者》（The Man Who Knew Everything）吗？
Something like that. Dev Patel plays Raman Ajan. And they're also known as taxicab numbers, but they're numbers that are expressible two different ways as the sum of two cubes. So there's this famous anecdote from history where Ramon Ajan is getting out of a taxicab. And his advisor, I'm not gonna remember his name. There's Littlewood, and then there's one other guy. And he says, oh, that's, he remarks, that's not a really intriguing number. And then Ramon goes, what are you talking about? 1729. It's, it's a number that is expressible two different ways as a sum of two cubes. And it's so it's, it's 10 cubed plus 9 cubed, and I believe, I can't remember,
差不多吧。戴夫·帕特尔饰演拉马努金。它们也被称为出租车数，但它们是可以以两种不同方式表示为两个立方数之和的数。所以历史上有一个著名的轶事，拉马努金正从一辆出租车里下来。他的导师，我记不得他的名字了。有利特尔伍德，然后还有另外一个人。然后他说，哦，那是——他评论道，那真不是一个引人入胜的数字。然后拉马努金说，你在说什么呢？1729。它是一个可以以两种不同方式表示为两个立方数之和的数字。所以它——它是10的三次方加9的三次方，并且我相信，我记不清了，
1 cubed plus 13 cubed maybe, something like that. Why taxicab? Because Ramon Ajan was getting out of a taxicab where the taxicab number was 1729, and that's where they got given his name. That wall behind you needs like a picture. It's something. It's sad right now.
1的三次方加13的三次方也许，诸如此类。为什么叫出租车？因为拉马努金当时正从一辆出租车里出来，那辆出租车的出租车编号是1729，这就是这个名字的由来。你身后的那面墙需要一幅画什么的。太空了。现在看起来太冷清了。
It's sad and lonely. I mean, I will give you that it is lonely in my place. I wouldn't say it's necessarily sad. I've got like eight plants. I've got like a little garden A greenhouse My apartment is basically a greenhouse I have no plants I'm very Some people
它又孤单又寂寞。我是说，我承认我这里确实很孤单。我不会说它一定很冷清。我有大概八盆植物。我有一个小花园，一个温室。我的公寓基本上就是一个温室。我没有植物。我很——有些人
Some people move to New York And they're like I miss having a place to go outside I miss having a backyard That's not me I'm very happy in my sterile Apartment that has nothing living in it aside from me yep it's uh i don't know you should get some nasa plants i know it's nasa java java uh
有些人搬到纽约，然后他们说我怀念有地方可以去户外，我怀念有个后院。那可不是我。我对自己的无菌公寓感到非常满意，里面除了我之外没有任何有生命的东西。是的，这——呃，我不知道，你应该弄一些NASA推荐的植物，我知道那是NASA，加瓦，加瓦，呃
nasa nasa um the nasa approved plants that like uh they they clean oxygen and like super did you freeze or are you just very still you're not just very still i'm just very still um anyway it's enough about plants we also so we have to talk about we have to talk about the associate so this this is going to get a bit technical i apologize to listeners for if this becomes really boring you don't apologize to listeners now do you oh yes we apologize to you the listener we gotta be the only podcast where there's two co-hosts and one pings them hey hey we gotta stop referring to them in the aggregate we gotta singular let's connect with them more one-on-one and then it becomes just meta because the first episode we're recording 30 of our discussion is like no no no connor what did we talk about we talked about that there's only one listener. You hear that? He's listening or she's
NASA，NASA，呃，那些NASA认证的植物，它们可以——它们清洁氧气，而且超级——你是死机了还是只是非常安静？你不是只是非常安静，我只是非常安静。呃，不管怎样，植物就聊到这吧。我们还必须讨论——我们必须讨论关联性——所以这会变得有点技术性，如果这变得非常无聊，我向听众道歉。你现在不用向听众道歉，是吗？哦，对，我们向你，听众道歉。我们得是唯一一个这样的播客：有两个联合主持人，而其中一个发信息给他们，嘿，嘿，我们得停止用统称来指代他们了。我们得用单数，多跟他们进行一对一的交流，然后这就变得非常元叙事了，因为我们录制的第一集，我们30%的讨论都是：不，不，不，康纳，我们在讨论什么？我们在讨论只有一个听众。听到没？他在听，或者她在
listening. They're listening right now. There's only one of them. All right, here we go. So what happened? CEEF, C-E-A-F, it's going to be a big deal, Combinator Enabled Algorithm Fusion. It's going to be the foundation upon which potentially a programming language will be written in the future is this the programming language that when you started working at nvidia i told you you were going to write and you gave me an incredulous look and did that thing where you giggle and laugh that uh as far as i can recall never happened i'm not sure what you're talking about there were witnesses giggling is not something that i believe i'm capable of i i'm i'm gonna spare you dear listener from me repeating the story again of the time that connor giggled at the mention of sean parent but continue okay okay uh that's fair um but anyways i posted i posted so actually
听。他们现在正在听。他们只有一个。好吧，我们开始吧。所以发生了什么？CEEF，C-E-A-F，这将会是一件大事，组合子启用算法融合（Combinator Enabled Algorithm Fusion）。它将成为未来潜在的编程语言赖以编写的基础。这难道就是你在英伟达开始工作时，我告诉你你要去写的那个编程语言吗？你当时还用怀疑的眼神看着我，发出那种咯咯的傻笑。呃，据我回忆，这从没发生过。我不知道你在说什么。当时有证人。咯咯笑不是我认为自己能做出的行为。我——我——我要免去你，亲爱的听众，再次听我重复康纳在听到肖恩·帕伦特（Sean Parent）的名字时咯咯笑的故事的痛苦，但我们继续。好吧，好吧，这很公平。不过，不管怎样，我发布了——我发布了——所以实际上
what happened is on the most recent or was it two episodes of array cast ago um at the tail end of it i had mentioned the possibility of like building an array language that uh took advantage of the fact that if you built it up of primitives and you knew all the properties algebraic properties of the primitives like if whether they're associative or commutative you could like fuse your operations down to whatever the bare minimum of what needed to be done and then on top of that if it was like a reduction at the end of the day you would know that the like combination or composition of all those binary operations, you'd know the associativity or commutativity of it. And then let me get his name right. Troll
发生的事情是，在最近的一期或两期前的Array Cast节目中，在节目接近尾声的时候，我曾提到过这样一种可能性：构建一种数组语言，它利用了这样一种事实：如果你用原语构建它，并且你知道原语的所有代数属性，比如它们是否具有结合律或交换律，你就可以将你的操作融合到需要完成的最基本的最简操作。然后在基础之上，如果最终是一个规约（reduction），你就会知道所有这些二元操作的组合或复合，你会知道它的结合律或交换律。然后，让我把他的名字念对。特罗尔（Troll）
Henriksen, I believe trolls Henriksen. I apologize if I'm pronouncing incorrectly your name. We went back and forth on Twitter a tiny bit. And so trolls is the I'm not sure if he's the creator, but he is working on the Futhark language, which is like a GPU slash Haskell slash sort of functional programming language. And basically at one point, he asked for some example code. I posted that example code. And then his response was
亨里克森（Henriksen），我相信是特罗尔·亨里克森。如果我把你的名字发音拼错了我向你道歉。我们在推特上来来回回聊了一小会儿。所以特罗尔是——我不确定他是不是创始人，但他正在致力于Futhark语言的开发，这是一种类似于GPU斜杠Haskell斜杠某种函数式编程语言的东西。基本上在某个时候，他要求提供一些示例代码。我发布了那些示例代码。然后他的回应是
that operation is not associative. And let me find that. Yeah, show me this operation. And so what I thought was that basically the binary operation had a pair as the left argument of the binary operation. And just a single element for the right argument. So it's definitely not commutative. And based on his definition, it made sense to say that it wasn't associative,
那个操作不满足结合律。让我在找找。对，把这个操作展示给我看。所以我想的是，基本上这个二元操作以一个二元组（pair）作为二元操作的左参数。而右参数只有一个元素。所以它绝对不满足交换律。根据他的定义，说它不满足结合律是说得通的，
but it was the same pattern that we had when we were solving that maximum consecutive ones. And the way we solved that was by creating a function object in the form of a struct that overloaded the function call operator like three or four different times for dealing with the different cases of do I have sort of that information, like information struct and a single element? Or do I have two like information structs on the left and right? So it dealt with the cases of like, am I doing my first little pass on a chunk of the array and building up the information
但它和我们解决“最大连续1的个数”时所用的模式是一样的。我们解决这个问题的方法是，通过创建一个结构体（struct）形式的函数对象，重载函数调用操作符大约三到四次，用来处理不同情况下的问题：我是不是拥有那种信息，比如信息结构体和一个单一元素？或者我左边和右边是否有两个像这样的信息结构体？所以它处理了这些情况，比如：我是不是在对数组的一个区块进行第一次小型遍历并建立信息，
and then doing like the down sweep and the up sweep? But like, does that not qualify as associative? So I'm looking at your Godbolt example here. Which operator are we talking about? Is it the one in the K function or the K2 function or the scan reduce lift function? But I wonder whether maybe him and us are working from a different definition of what associative means. If you look at either K2.
然后进行下扫（down sweep）和上扫（up sweep）？但是，这难道不符合结合律的资格吗？所以我正在看你这里的Godbolt示例。我们在讨论哪个操作符？是K函数里的那个，还是K2函数里的那个，还是扫描-规约-提升（scan reduce lift）函数里的那个？但我很好奇，也许他和我们对“结合律”的定义有着不同的理解。如果你看K2中的任何一个。
Yeah. K2 is the easiest because it's not split into that scan reduce lift thing so basically what what we're looking at just so that we're not just randomly talking about some godbolt example is we're looking at three different solutions to caddane's algorithm and caddane's algorithm is a solution to solving the maximum uh subarray sum problem. So if you're given a list of numbers that are negative and positive, what's the longest contiguous sequence of elements such that it maximizes the sum of that subarray?
对。K2是最简单的，因为它没有被拆分成那种扫描-规约-提升的东西。所以基本上，我们正在看的是——为了不让我们只是随机地讨论某个Godbolt示例——我们正在看卡丹算法（Kadane's algorithm）的三种不同解决方案，而卡丹算法是解决最大子数组和问题的一种方案。所以如果你得到一个包含负数和正数的数字列表，最长的连续元素序列是什么，使得该子数组的和最大化？
So just do a proof. Like, just, you took a, you must have taken a class in college where you did proofs, right? I took discrete mathematics, but yeah. Here, let me send you the tweet that Trolls sent. I think that's the easiest way to think this through, is to just sit down and write out a proof. Maybe we can even do that now.
所以只要做一个证明。就像，你一定在大学里上过一门课，你在里面做过证明，对吧？我上过离散数学，但是是的。来吧，我把特罗尔发的那条推特发给你。我认为这是最容易把这件事想清楚的方法，就是坐下来写出一个证明。也许我们现在甚至就能做到这一点。
Essentially, you... But that's the thing. I think his point is that, so if you click that tweet, it'll bring you, I sent it in the chat. It says, how can f of x, so f that takes two parameters where the first one is x and the second one is f of y and z, be the same as if you switch the f of x and y, z, if they have different types. But that's the thing is like – Well, I think he's going along the same logic that I'm going along, that that statement that he has there in his tweet, that's what you want to prove. Just take your operator and plug it in and see what happens. Well, so that's why I'm getting back to the maximum consecutive ones problem. So if you haven't listened to that, that was a couple episodes actually,
本质上，你……但这就是关键所在。我想他的意思是，所以如果你点击那条推特，它会把你带到——我把它发在聊天里了。上面写着：f(x)中的f接收两个参数，其中第一个是x，第二个是f(y, z)，怎么能跟如果你把f(x, y)和z调换位置是一样的呢，如果它们的类型不同的话？但这就是问题所在——嗯，我想他遵循的逻辑和我遵循的逻辑是一样的，他在推特上的那个陈述，正是你想去证明的。只需带入你的操作符并运行它，看看会发生什么。好吧，所以这就是我要回到“最大连续1的个数”问题的原因。所以如果你没听过那一期，那是好几期前的事了，其实——
but the one where we really dive into it and then it's called the loss reduction episode 25. I was going to say, don't you recall that like in that function object, like we have overloaded the function call operator. And that's where the disagreement between us and him comes up so he's he's asking how can f of x comma f y z be equal to f of f x y comma z if f y comma z has a different type than z yeah um and then he asks maybe we are using different definitions of associative and i think he's right that we are because in in our thinking um uh overloading you know f could be an overloaded function, right? That F could take,
但我们在那一期中深入探讨了它，它被称为“损失规约”，第25集。我本来想说，难道你不记得在那个函数对象中，我们重载了函数调用操作符吗？这就是我们和他产生分歧的地方。所以他——他正在问：如果f(y, z)的类型与z不同，那么f(x, f(y, z))怎么能等于f(f(x, y), z)呢？对，呃——然后他问，也许我们在使用不同的结合律定义，我想他是对的，我们确实在使用不同的定义。因为在我们的思考中，呃，重载，你知道，f可以是一个重载函数，对吧？f可以接受——
it could take either, you know, a pair as the second argument, or it could take a scalar element. But I think... Isn't that cheating? I feel like that's cheating, is that like, so like, isn't, aren't we bending the definition of associative then? Yes. I mean, I think it's hard to say. Isn't this in the ISO standard? Like, do we define what we mean by associative? I don't think so. I mean, it's really, but the question isn't what we define as associative here. The question is, what do we define as an operation?
它可以接受——要么是一个二元组作为第二个参数，要么它可以接受一个标量元素。但我觉得……这难道不是作弊吗？我觉得这像是在作弊，就像是——难道，难道我们不是在曲解结合律的定义吗？是的。我的意思是，我觉得很难说。这难道不是在ISO标准里吗？比如说，我们是否定义了我们所说的结合律是什么意思？我不这么认为。我的意思是，这真的很——但问题不在这里，我们在这里把什么定义为结合律。问题是，我们把什么定义为一个操作？
Like, what do we define as f? If we say that f is only a single overload, then yeah, this couldn't be associative. But if we say that f is an overload set or if f is a function object um then sure this this could be um uh associative and i think i would even argue from um from like a mathematical grounds i don't see any reason that you couldn't define, uh, uh, of, of, of function this way. Um, you know, there's, there's, there's no reason to restrict yourself to, uh, uh, just to requiring that the second parameter is just a single type. And in fact, I would go a step further. One of the tricks that I used in that maximum consecutive ones in a couple of my little prototypes was
就像，我们把f定义为什么？如果我们说f只有一个重载，那好吧，这就不可能是结合律。但如果我们说f是一个重载集，或者如果f是一个函数对象，呃，那当然，这就可以是——呃，结合律。而且我想我甚至会从——呃，数学的基础上进行辩论，我看不出有什么理由你不能以这种方式定义一个函数。呃，你知道，没有任何理由将你自己限制在——呃，仅仅要求第二个参数必须只是单一类型。事实上，我会更进一步。我在那个“最大连续1的个数”以及我的几个小原型中使用的技巧之一是
relying on implicit conversions so this reduction that you're doing it's a reduction over what like a pair of int and then what's the data type this is the data type like int for the input sequence yeah basically it's a pair of int and then what's the data type this is the data type like int for for the input sequence yeah basically it's a pair of ints and one of them represents sort of a internal scan that we're doing and then the other int represents a maximum value over that scan which the point is is that like when you have a scam followed by a reduction you don't actually need to do the scan in terms of like writing to a linear amount of memory. You can just fuse those into a single reduction.
依赖于隐式转换。所以你正在做的这个规约，它是一个针对什么的规约——比如一个int的二元组，然后数据类型是什么？这就是数据类型，就像输入序列的int一样。是的，基本上它是一个int的二元组，其中一个代表我们正在进行的某种内部扫描，然后另一个int代表该扫描上的最大值。重点是，当你有一个扫描后面跟着一个规约时，你实际上不需要就写入线性数量的内存而言去进行扫描。你只需将它们融合成一个单一的规约。
So, you know, one way that you could implement this operator is you could have one overload that takes pair and then, you know, pair events and then int. And then you could have one overload that takes pair events and then pair events, and then int. And then you could have one over there that takes pair events and then pair events. But you could also pick some sentinel value. You know, what is the second pair? Like in this pair events, what are the two values that are represented? The first value in the pair is the maximum. So like you see how we're doing a dot first at the very end?
所以，你知道，你可以实现这个操作的一种方法是，你可以有一个重载接收二元组——二元组的int，然后是一个int。然后你可以有一个重载接收二元组的int，然后是二元组的int，再然后是一个int。然后你可以有一个重载在那里接收二元组的int，然后是二元组的int。但你也可以选择某个哨兵值。你知道，第二个二元组是什么？就像在这个二元组的int中，代表了哪两个值？二元组中的第一个值是最大值。所以就像你看到我们在最末尾是如何做.first的吗？
Yeah, yeah. That's our actual result that we're collecting. And then the second value is the running sum that's sort of being floored at certain points in time. So basically, if you were doing if you were if you wanted to take just a single element and construct one of these pairs from it, you could do that. Yeah, you would basically you would just add it to the second one and then you would set it as the first one as well, because that's going to be the maximum at that point in time, unless if it's negative, of course. So then instead of defining your operation as an associative operation over the set of like ints and the set of these pairs and having this problem of dealing with heterogeneous types, you could just think about your operation as being an operation that only operates on these pairs and that you would just convert those the ints to the pair just do a transformer yeah or yeah and like like like you know you could one you could actually do this in your implementation you instead of using stood pair you could implement your own little struct type that has a constructor that takes a single int, and it's not an explicit constructor so that it will actually implicitly convert. You could do that.
对，对。那是我们正在收集的实际结果。然后第二个值是运行中的和，它在某些时间点上被赋底值（floored）。所以基本上，如果你在做——如果你想只取一个元素并用它构造这些二元组之一，你可以做到。是的，基本上你只需把它加到第二个上面，然后你把它也设为第一个，因为这将是那个时间点的最大值，当然，如果是负数的话除外。所以，与其将你的操作定义为对int集和这些二元组集的结合操作，并面临处理异构类型的这个问题，不如将你的操作看作是一个只对这些二元组进行操作的操作，然后你只需将int转换为二元组——做一个变换，对吧？或者，就像——就像——你知道的，你实际上可以在你的实现中做到这一点，与其使用std::pair，不如实现你自己的小结构体类型，它有一个接受单个int的构造函数，而且它不是一个显式构造函数，这样它实际上会进行隐式转换。你可以这么做。
But my point is really more that this is a theoretical exercise that I think demonstrates that the operation is indeed associative and it can be associative over a single type if you make that single type this collection of pairs. I do see his point, but I do think that he's wrong. I do think that this is an associative operation. I think that in the worst case, you could explain it as an associative operation over these you know these pairs right but like i from him looking at the code where you see that it's they're not both pairs the binary operation as a pair on the left and an element on the right it's definitely like when he asked the question i was like yeah he seems right but i know that we worked through this in the previous maximum consecutive ones and we did that by overloading the function call operator yeah and then my question was like so either either
但我的观点其实更多是，这是一个理论练习，我认为它证明了该操作确实是结合的，并且如果你使该单一类型成为这些二元组的集合，它就可以在一个单一类型上是结合的。我确实明白他的观点，但我确实认为他是错的。我确实认为这是一个结合操作。我认为在最坏的情况下，你可以将其解释为对这些——你知道的，这些二元组的结合操作——但是，就像我从他看代码的角度来看，你看到它们不都是二元组，二元操作左边是一个二元组，右边是一个元素，这绝对就像——当他问这个问题时，我就想，是的，他看起来是对的，但我知道我们在上一次的“最大连续1的个数”中解决过这个问题，我们是通过重载函数调用操作符来做到这一点的。是的，然后我的问题就像是，要么——
we're like we've taken the word associative and sort of redefined it for our own sake or um you're allowed to call that op like if the operation can do different things that is also a valid in terms of it being associative either Either way, I'm not sure which one's right, but Henrik, this is for you, or not, sorry, Henrik, Henriksen, Trolls Henriksen. Yeah, that's, I guess, the answer. Do you have a sense of whether which one it is? Like from, what do you think the mathematicians are saying, that we're like, we're speaking blasphemy right now? I'm not sure. I'll say this. I think overloading is such an intuitive part of C++. I feel like somebody would clip that because overloading, of course, can be a fairly complex aspect of C++ that can be hard to understand.
我们要么把“结合”这个词拿来为我们自己的利益重新定义了，要么，你被允许调用那个操作——如果操作可以做不同的事情，这在它是结合的方面也是有效的。无论哪种方式，我都不确定哪个是对的，但亨里克——这是给你的，或者不，抱歉，亨里克森，特罗尔·亨里克森。是的，我想这就是答案。你觉得它是哪一种？从——你认为数学家们会怎么说，我们现在是在说亵渎神明的话吗？我不太确定。我这样说吧。我认为重载是C++中非常直观的一部分。我觉得有人会剪辑这段话，因为重载当然可能是C++中相当复杂的一个方面，可能很难理解。
But when I say it's intuitive, what I mean is it's a tool that we reach for so frequently that we take it for granted and that we don't perhaps even think about all the implications of that. And let me explain it a step further. When we as C++ programmers talk about an operation, either, you know, an operation that's defined as functions, or maybe it's defined as a customization point object, but like a named operation, like std reduce, let's use this as an example. We think of that as a single entity, right? That's a single thing. Maybe we even say like it's a single function.
但当我说它很直观时，我的意思是它是我们经常使用的一个工具，以至于我们认为这是理所当然的，而且我们甚至可能没有考虑过它的所有含义。让我再进一步解释一下。当我们作为C++程序员谈论一个操作时，无论是——你知道，定义为函数的的操作，或者可能定义为定制点对象（customization point object）的操作，但就像一个命名的操作，比如std::reduce，让我们用这个作为例子。我们认为它是一个单一的实体，对吧？那是一单一的东西。也许我们甚至会说它是一个单一的函数。
And I consciously avoided saying the word function when I was just describing that there, because I didn't want to add confusion to it. But in reality, the named thing stood colon colon reduce is actually multiple different overloads. It's multiple different function definitions. And that's how you implement it. And another interesting aspect of this is that in some cases, especially when you're dealing with defaulted parameters,
而我在刚才描述的时候，是有意识地避免使用“函数”这个词的，因为我不想给它增加困惑。但实际上，这个被命名为std::reduce的东西实际上是多个不同的重载。它是多个不同的函数定义。这就是你实现它的方式。而这另一个有趣的方面是，在某些情况下，特别是当你处理默认参数时，
you have the choice where you could either say, I'm going to implement this function with a single overload that has defaulted parameters, or I'll implement it with multiple overloads without the defaulted parameter. And the distinction between the two isn't really observable. And in fact, we give standard library implementers the freedom to pick which of these, to pick, to choose to do this either with more overloads or less overloads when they can, when they have defaulted parameters. The point I'm getting at is that we think about an overload set as being like one contiguous entity. And that's not, you know And that's not always the case.
你有两种选择：要么用带有默认参数的单个重载来实现这个函数，要么用没有默认参数的多个重载来实现它。这两者之间的区别其实并不是很明显。事实上，我们赋予了标准库实现者自由选择的权利：当他们有默认参数时，既可以选择用更多的重载来实现，也可以选择用更少的重载来实现。我想说的是，我们把一组重载视为一个连续的实体。但你知道的，事实并非总是如此。
Sometimes different overloads have different functionality. We try to avoid that. We generally think that that's not good design. In fact, one of my key library design rules is that all of the overloads of a function should have the same semantics, the same general semantics. And likewise, all of the specializations of a class template should have the same semantics
有时不同的重载具有不同的功能。我们尽量避免这种情况。我们通常认为这不是好的设计。事实上，我的核心库设计规则之一就是：一个函数的所有重载都应该具有相同的语义，即相同的通用语义。同样地，一个类模板的所有特化也应该具有相同的语义
and the same, the same set of member functions and the same interfaces because we're going to think of those things as being a single entity. But there's other ways in which overloads can be quirky too. Different overloads can return different things, which can sometimes be surprising. The parallel overload of for each returns void. The scalar overloads return the function object. The parallel versions, of course, can't return that function object because that function object, it may have been stateful.
以及相同的一组成员函数和相同的接口，因为我们要把这些东西看作是一个单一的实体。但重载也可能以其他方式表现出奇特之处。不同的重载可以返回不同的结果，有时这会令人惊讶。for_each 的并行重载返回 void。标量重载则返回函数对象。当然，并行版本不能返回该函数对象，因为该函数对象可能是带状态的。
And that's the reason why the scalar version of, or the sequential version of for each returns it is because you might've passed in some function object that was gonna accumulate some data and then you wanna get it back later. Well, we couldn't support that in the parallel version. So we didn't. And we didn't return you the function object
这就是 for_each 的标量版本（或顺序版本）会返回它的原因，因为你可能传入了一些会累积某些数据的函数对象，然后你想在之后把它取回来。嗯，我们在并行版本中无法支持这一点。所以我们没有这样做。而且我们也没有把函数对象返回给你
because there was no reason for us to do that because there was nothing useful you could do with it. But that's a little funky to have a operation under one name that has two different return types. And likewise, you can have a variety of different parameters that a single named operation can take of a variety of different types. And I think we perhaps take it for granted that operations work like that in C++.
因为我们没有理由这样做，对你来说也没有什么有用的事情可以用它来做。但是，一个同名操作却具有两种不同的返回类型，这确实有点古怪。同样地，单个命名操作可以接受各种不同类型的大量不同参数。我想我们或许已经理所当然地认为 C++ 中的操作就是这样的。
And maybe this fellow coming from a, it sounds like a more Haskell background and a background from other programming languages, maybe in his mind, a named function or a single operation should be something that has, you know, the same signature. And so maybe that's what what was bothering him um but i i could see i could see even even coming from a like similar background but you're like i i'm not a a trained mathematician so i'm not sure in the world of mathematics what they consider like the definitive definition of associative and um i wouldn't be surprised though, if many mathematicians saw that, you know, the pair on like, not even just type A on one side and type B on another side and said, well, clearly that's not associative. I think if you looked at the math definition,
也许这位朋友来自一个（听起来像是）更偏向 Haskell 背景以及其他编程语言背景的人，也许在他心目中，一个命名函数或单个操作应该具有相同的签名。所以也许这就是困扰他的地方……不过，我能理解，即使来自类似的背景，你也会想：“我不是一个受过专业训练的数学家，所以我不确定在数学世界里他们对结合律的最终定义是什么”，而且如果很多数学家看到这一点，我一点也不会感到奇怪，比如，不仅是一侧是 A 类型、另一侧是 B 类型的那种配对，然后说：“嗯，显然这不具备结合律。”我想如果你去查数学定义的话，
yeah, I think if you looked at the math definition, it would have to be associative defined on some set of objects. And that set of things shouldn't be heterogeneous. But I'm not really sure, because the definitions of associative in the math world that I'm familiar with work like that, but it's possible that there are more complex definitions of associative uh that do have a notion of you know heterogeneity but i definitely think that at the very least you could define the set of objects that this operation operates on as being those pairs not the ints and the pairs right right you've solved your problem right i uh we should put i feel like we should put a disclaimer on the our website we do have a website by the way we never mention it
是的，我想如果你去看数学定义，结合律必须是在某个对象集合上定义的。而那个对象集合不应该是异构的。但我不太确定，因为我熟悉的数学世界里的结合律定义就是这样的，不过也可能存在更复杂的结合律定义，它们确实包含某种异构性的概念……但我绝对认为，至少你可以将这个操作所作用的对象集合定义为那些二元组，而不是整型和二元组，对吧？对吧？你把你的问题解决了，对吧？我……我们应该在网站上放一个声明——顺便说一句，我们确实有一个网站，我们从来没提过它
but it's uh adsp the podcast.com and maybe we should call it the title of this episode like surprise uh we are not mathematicians i i i have a math degree i mean i studied actuarial science which is like in in the math world but uh but um you know i feel like we're too bryce has just run off to go get something but i'm going to continue to talk but uh i feel like we're we're two developers that are math inclined but you know we're talking about the definition of associativity and opining on it when really we should just have a math person on and we should have a, we should, Oh, ADSP should have like a, like, so if you study pure mathematics, or maybe, maybe Lisa Lippincott would be great for that.
但它是 adsp the podcast.com，也许我们应该把这一集的标题叫做“惊喜：我们不是数学家”。我有一个数学学位——我是说我学的是精算学，这在数学界里也算，但是……你知道，我觉得我们太……布莱斯（Bryce）刚刚跑去拿什么东西了，但我还是要继续说下去……不过，我觉得我们是两个对数学感兴趣的开发者，但你知道，我们在讨论结合律的定义并对此发表高见，而实际上我们应该请一位数学专家来，我们应该……哦，ADSP 应该有一个，比如，如果你研究纯数学，或者也许丽莎·利平科特（Lisa Lippincott）会非常适合这个。
I think you should narrate what I'm doing, by the way. All right. I'll start doing that. So Lisa, you probably don't listen, but if you are listening, would you want to be our math consultant and every couple well a couple we will accrue our math questions and then have you on every once in a while um and also too lisa's got a crazy fascinating story it'd be awesome to have her on just for her to i'm sure she has some crazy stories similar to Sean. So, yeah, narrating.
顺便说一句，你应该旁白一下我在做什么。好的，我开始这么做。所以，丽莎，你可能不听，但如果你正在听的话，你愿意成为我们的数学顾问吗？每隔几周，我们会积累一些数学问题，然后偶尔请你上节目。而且，丽莎还有一个非常迷人的疯狂故事，能请她来上节目光是听她讲故事就很棒了，我确信她有一些类似于肖恩（Sean）的疯狂故事。所以，是的，旁白中。
I don't actually know. Bryce has got a package that's something he's wrapped up. You can hear in the background he's got scissors. There's a 37% chance he's going to stab himself. These are very nice scissors, by the way. Yeah, of course they are. I'm sure they're imported from Italy. They've got a mahogany handle. Imported from Japan. They don't have a mahogany
其实我不知道。布莱斯拿了一个包裹，那是他刚包装好的东西。你能在背景里听到他拿着剪刀。他有 37% 的概率会捅到自己。顺便说一句，这是一把非常好的剪刀。是的，当然是。我敢肯定是进口自意大利的。它们有红木手柄。是从日本进口的。它们没有红木
handle, but they are high carbon steel. They're very good. The fact that even Bryce has to clarify that his scissors don't have a mahogany handle is like the perfect summary. So this actually, this
手柄，但它们是高碳钢的。它们非常好。事实上，布莱斯甚至不得不澄清他的剪刀没有红木手柄，这简直是完美的总结。所以实际上，这
didn't come in the stuff that just arrived yesterday. This traveled with me, but this is my Louisiana State University diploma. And can you read that? It says, Louisiana State University and Agricultural and Mechanical College, on the nomination of the faculty of the college of science has conferred upon bryce alexander whoa i didn't know you had a second middle name adelstein lelback actually i think i did know that um the degree of bachelor of science with all the honors rights and privileges
并不是昨天刚送到的那些东西里的。这是跟我一起旅行带来的，这是我的路易斯安那州立大学毕业证书。你能读懂那个吗？上面写着：“路易斯安那州立大学暨农业与机械学院，在科学学院全体教职员的提名下，已授予布莱斯·亚历山大——哇，我不知道你还有第二个中间名阿德尔斯坦·莱尔巴克（Adelstein Lelback）——其实我好像知道这件事……授予其理学学士学位，并享有与该学位相关的所有荣誉、
of that degree appertaining you got to move it up a little bit. Oh, yeah. Wait, wait. It doesn't say what my major was. Crap. Well, I assure you, I assure you,
权利和特权。”你得把它往上拿一点。哦，对。等等，等等。上面没写我的专业是什么？糟糕。好吧，我向你保证，我向你保证，
I had a major in applied mathematics. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我主修的是应用数学。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家有个美好的一天。本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。